you have a teenager and now you have a
baby you do and what's that like and
how's that balance and we're talking
about all boys I know it's evening out
how is that it's great it's a lot right
now I mean it's I'm not gonna lie
it's you know it's it's busy in the
house it's a lot and trying to juggle
and manage and balance is a daily you
know it's like a it's like the family
like Huddle's around and it's like
everyone gets their strategy and then
we're like you know hi like let's do
this
let's spread out you know and but it's
good you know when you have them because
there's seven seven years apart so
riders 7 from Bing and Bing 7 Vermont
which means I basically been having
children my entire adult life as a
father how's Danny and how do you see
him in a different light now yeah Danny
is the greatest I feel like I hit the
jackpot and his a bit like his natural
ability as a dad is just amazing to
watch you know and yeah I mean he's he's
also just an incredibly supportive
partner for me that I've that's a nice a
nice thing to have how did this whole
deal come about with WWE I started
fabletics five years ago it's an active
wear company it's all about health and
wellness and leading an active lifestyle
and that really did became sort of the
center of my what's always been a
passion of mine which is you know trying
to be as healthy as you can and live
about more balanced lifestyle and WW
Mindy the CEO came to me and wanted to
talk about she was talking about this
reimagining of Weight Watchers and you
know where we are today in the world and
how she sees the her company and and I
never really knew anything about the
program so as she was talking to me
about it I realized I knew nothing about
it I thought it was a completely
different thing than what it actually is
and as we did kind of start sharing this
passion together I I recognized that it
was a great partnership for us because
it's what I'm passionate about what
they're doing is exactly what I always
talk about which is flexibility and
trying to understand what it is to be a
healthy life it's an ongoing journey
right I mean people say like well how do
you it's just your jeans and it's just
it's like well you can say that and
that's you know fine but it's a practice
like everything else everything that we
do in life whether it be my practicing
mindfulness practicing body movement
practicing health what goes in our
mouths I mean these are things that you
need to have be mindful or have
awareness and knowledge we need support
systems we need community the science
backs up the program and you know my
favorite statistic of it was the three
the top three things that that work at
what wlwt's number one you're gonna lose
weight we know that right we know you
start eating healthy you lose weight but
number two sleep better that sounds
really good but number three it makes
people feel happier and that as I get
older if I have a platform if there's
something I want to put out there it's
to try to inspire people to know what
makes them happy I have seen you on a
lot of red carpets we've done a lot of
interviews before and you have never
been a sad person and you've also been
one of the people who has always been
best dressed look how look she looks
amazing I've had a lot of luck but I've
also worked really hard and I'm a very
dedicated type of person and I'm very
ambitious in everything I do whether it
be in my goals as I work out how I have
I choose to like shift something in my
life I'm gonna shift it I'm gonna change
it
[Music]